[MUSIC PLAYING]
MOLINA: Good afternoon.
Welcome to the 21st annual
Victor P. Starr Memorial
Lecture.
As you know, we have
had these lectures
for over two decades in
these departments in honor
Victor Starr who was a faculty
in our department, actually
was the department of
meteorology when he was there.
And these lectures are
on broad ranging topics
in atmospheric sciences.
So we're very pleased to have
today the first such lecture
in atmospheric chemistry.
And we're particularly
pleased that it's
Professor Paul Crutzen who's
giving the presentation today.
Paul is a close colleague
and friend of mine.
And I think it's very
fitting that he will give us
this first atmospheric
chemistry lecture, because Paul
started as a meteorologist.
But eventually he saw the light
and became a chemist as well.
So let me tell you a
few things about Paul.
He was born in Amsterdam
in the Netherlands.
And what he studied
first I believe
was engineering in Amsterdam.
In fact, his first jobs
were as an engineer
in the bridge
construction bureau
of the city of Amsterdam.
Then eventually
he moved to Sweden
where he was working at the
house construction bureau.
But eventually he got
a PhD in meteorology
at the University of
Stockholm in Sweden.
I think he started there
with the job as a computer
programmer, but
switched to meteorology.
Between 1974 and 1980, he
came to the United States
where he was the director of the
air quality division at NCAR.
I think we call it the
atmospheric chemistry
division at the National Center
for Atmospheric Research.
And in 1980, he
went back to Europe,
to Germany, where he
has been there until now
as a director of the
atmospheric chemistry
division of the Max Planck
Institute [INAUDIBLE] in Mainz.
At the same time he
has been and is still
a part-time professor at
the Scripps Institution
of Oceanography in San Diego
as well in Utrecht University
in the Netherlands.
Now, Paul has many honors and
awards, several pages, which
I won't take the time to read.
But I thought I'd select just
a handful, with a certain bias,
as you will see.
One of them is he
is an AUG fellow.
He became a fellow of the
American Geophysical Union
in 1986.
I just became a fellow myself
just a year or two ago.
In 1989, he got the Tyler
Prize for the environment.
It happens to be a prize I also
received at some point in time.
Another very interesting
prize is the recipient
of the Max Planck
Forschungspreis, which
is a program that is given
to a German investigator
in collaboration with
an American scientist.
So I was fortunate to
receive that with Paul.
In fact, it was a
very productive prize,
because we got the
funding to do research,
and we wonderful
student, Thomas Coop who
was Paul's student to begin
with and became my student
afterwards.
And then in 1995, Paul received
the Nobel Prize in chemistry.
And of course, I had
the honor of sharing it
with him and with
Sherwood Rowland.
So these are the only
prizes I will mention.
[LAUGHTER]
But let me do one
additional thing.
I want to read you the
title of his PhD theses
in 1968 that he got at the
University of Stockholm.
And it is "The termination
of parameters appearing
in the dry and the wet
photochemical theories of ozone
in the stratosphere."
So that was in 1968.
So this really brings
me to explain to you
that this groundbreaking
work in understanding
how the stratosphere
functions, how
the chemistry of the
stratosphere works,
really discovering the
catalytic cycles, the nature
of these cycles is very
important in explaining how we
see that trace species, in
this case nitrogen oxides
or hydrogen oxides, very small
amounts of certain catalysts
can have this very large effect
i controlling the abundance
of ozone in the stratosphere.
And also in Stockholm,
Paul had a second thesis.
I think it's a doctorate
in science thesis.
This was in 1973.
And the title is "On
the photochemistry
of ozone in the
stratosphere and troposphere
and pollution of
the stratosphere
by high flying aircraft."
So this is another milestone.
Paul was really the
first one to recognize
that human activities
could impact ozone
in the stratosphere, which
is this major natural system,
that's truly a global issue.
So it all goes back to
his early days in Sweden.
Since then he has made
numerous contributions, both
to stratospheric
chemistry, as well
as to tropospheric chemistry,
again too many for me to list.
But he will talk to us today
about tropospheric chemistry.
The title of his presentation
is "The Major Role
of the Tropics in Atmospheric
Chemistry, the Need
for Strong Research Efforts."
I give you Paul Crutzen.
[APPLAUSE]
CRUTZEN: Well, thank you
for this introduction.
Now, you took 10
minutes of my talk.
[LAUGHTER] So I have
to shorten it down
I guess because everybody wants
to go to the drinks afterwards.
Well, it's nice to
be here and in fact
to have such an audience
so late in the evening,
because normally this
time I go to bed.
Well, my lecture will not
be really for the experts.
So this will be a little
bit of a fundamental lecture
on how the chemistry of
the atmosphere works.
So if the experts already
know that and they know it,
they can leave.
But you're also allowed to stay.
If you look at the distribution
of ozone in the atmosphere,
and we all know that
almost everything
is in the stratosphere.
And about the stratosphere
I will not speak very much
at this lecture.
There's very little
ozone in the troposphere.
At most, 10% of all
atmospheric ozone
is located in the troposphere.
And for a long time, it was
thought that ozone was not
very interesting.
And some meteorologists
had been looking at it.
It was normally
believed that ozone
would come down from
the stratosphere
into the troposphere
and would be
destroyed at the Earth surface.
This was basically the
belief, say, around 1970.
And in fact, ozone is
of course coming down
from the stratosphere
and the troposphere.
This is the picture which was
prevalent in the early days.
Ozone was produced
in the stratosphere.
And a very small
fraction of it--
actually the flux of ozone
from the stratosphere
into the troposphere
is less than 1%
of all ozone formed
in the stratosphere.
So a little small
leakage will bring ozone
into the troposphere.
But it was believed
for a very long time,
that that was the whole
story, that it was then
they destroyed at the ground.
And that this happens
is also sometimes
very clearly observed.
Here, we have a
so-called intrusion
of material from
the stratosphere
into the troposphere.
We see here isolines of
radioactive species, which
in the '50s was produced
copiously in the stratosphere
by bomb testing.
We see ozone, and
we see something
in meteorologically stable
or almost inert capacity,
namely, the potential vorticity.
And you see all these isolines
going into the troposphere.
And part of this ozone,
which follows that
is then also staying
in the troposphere.
So the picture looked
extremely clear.
And in fact, very
little interest
was devoted to ozone
in the troposphere
until roughly the
middle of the '70s.
We all know how
important ozone is.
The stratospheric ozone filters
out basically all radiation
between 240 and 300 nanometer
which is coming down
on the Earth from the sun.
However, this filtering
is not perfect.
Around 300 nanometer
UV radiation
comes down to the surface,
very much dependent
on the amount of ozone
in the stratosphere.
And this radiation is harmful.
Too much of it, we all know
it in summertime, sun burns.
Too much of it is
not good for you.
So that is normally the
UV radiation is considered
to be a negative effect.
Also, ozone in the troposphere
is considered to be negative.
It harms people.
Lungs can be damaged and so on.
And plant life can be
damaged by too much ozone
in the troposphere.
However it turns out that
this ozone in the troposphere
has also very important, let's
call it, positive consequences.
And one of the reasons is that--
and it goes back to some
simple reactions here--
ozone photolysis at
wavelength below--
nowadays we say
almost 400 nanometer--
below in this wavelength
region produces O atoms
in an electronically sized
state, O single D, which
then has enough energy
to react with water vapor
to make hydroxyl radicals,
hence these hydroxyl radicals,
which play an enormously
important role
in keeping the atmosphere clean,
because the hydroxyl radicals
react with almost
all species, which
are produced by
nature or by mankind
and deposited in the atmosphere.
So if we summarize the
two reactions again--
by the way, you see here that
because of these two reactions,
ozone is destroyed.
We come back to that, to budget
of ozone in the troposphere.
And we see here a number of
species which react with OH,
like methane.
Methane reacts rather slowly
with the hydroxyl radical.
And it has a lifetime on
average around the world
of about 8 years.
And that means that methane
is found both in the northern
and in the southern hemisphere,
although almost all methane is
produced in the
northern hemisphere.
But we go to other species
like ethane reacts much faster
with OH.
And we see definitely much
more in the northern hemisphere
than in the southern hemisphere.
We go to propane, lifetime
of a few days, 10 days.
And we hardly find
anything of that
in the southern hemisphere.
And of course,
isoprene, which is
emitted by the
deciduous forests,
has such a short
lifetime, orders of hours,
that we only find this compound
close to the forest regions.
We have a number of sulfur,
chlorine, and many other gases,
which are removed from the
atmosphere by reaction with OH.
And this was a major discovery,
which goes back to 1971
by Chip Levy, who worked here
at the Smithsonian Institute,
just down the river almost.
Before this paper and
before this knowledge,
it will simply not
know how compounds
which go into the atmosphere,
how they are removed.
And I show you later
some funny estimates
about budgets of
trace gases, which
were produced at that time,
before that time, because they
were far out from reality.
Now, in the lowest figures,
the lowest two figures here,
I sort of summarize the good
and the bad of UV radiation.
Here, we have the
positive factor.
If we multiply the efficiency
with which O single
D atoms are produced by
ultraviolet radiation,
multiply that with the flux
of ultraviolet radiation
down to the Earth's
surface, which
is a strong function of ozone
going down to its shorter
wavelength, we get
curves which look
like this, dependent
on the amount of ozone
in the stratosphere.
That's the positive part.
But if you look
at the DNA damage,
we get a curve which
looks very similar.
So you cannot say that UV
radiation is only damaging.
It has positive, it
has negative sides.
In the '70s, it
was also realized
that the ozone in the
troposphere was not inert.
Of course, we saw
already one reaction
in which ozone is
destroyed, the photolysis
by ultraviolet radiation.
But also reactions
were discovered
in which ozone is either
produced or destroyed.
And the simplest set of
reactions which do the job we
can exemplify here by the
oxidation of carbon monoxide.
It starts by reaction with OH.
That's how most stuff is
removed from the atmosphere.
H atoms are formed in CO2.
O2 adds to the H atom.
HO2 is formed.
And then depending
on whether there
is enough NO in the
atmosphere, HO2 reacts with NO
to make OH and NO2.
Or in an other cycle,
HO2 can react with ozone
to make OH and 2O2.
If you go to this cycle, the
NO2, which is formed here,
is very quickly dissociated
in NO and O atoms.
And the O atoms recombine
with oxygen to make ozone.
The net result of
these reactions
are that CO is oxidized
with two oxygen molecules
into CO2 and ozone.
If there is too little
NO in the atmosphere,
then instead CO is oxidized
with CO2, but ozone is consumed.
And much depends on the amount
of NO in the atmosphere,
whether ozone is
produced or destroyed.
So basically, the borderline
is defined by the ratio
between NO and ozone.
And the rate constants
for various reactions
enter into this.
One can generally say that for
NO, mixing ratio is somewhere
greater than 10 to the
minus 11 in the atmosphere,
ozone is produced.
Otherwise it can be destroyed.
It's interesting to
look at these reactions.
In these photochemical reaction,
we can consider carbon monoxide
as a fuel.
It's a low
temperature combustion
of carbon monoxide we
are really looking at,
which is sort of the incinerated
by the presence of photons
in the atmosphere.
CO is the fuel.
And we see also that we have
lots of catalysts being active
in the production or the
destruction of ozone.
OH, HO2, NO, and
NO2, they all act as
catalysts in these reactions.
Now this is the simplest
set of reactions
which ozone is formed,
photochemically and sort
of smog type reactions.
The next simplest case
is methane oxidation,
which you see already many
more reactions entering
into the scheme.
But also methane is everywhere,
like carbon monoxide.
And if there's just enough
NO in the atmosphere,
then ozone is form.
And of course, if you go
to more complex molecules,
like isoprene, we get about
1,000 reactions to consider.
And just if there's enough
NO in the atmosphere ozone
is formed in the same way
as during the oxidation
of carbon monoxide.
Now NO is increasing in the
atmosphere and especially
because of emissions
at mid-latitudes
and also in the
tropics by biomass
burning, about which
I will speak much more
a little later in the talk.
With increased emissions
of NO in the atmosphere,
especially in
industrial regions,
and also increasing
concentrations of, say,
for instance, methane in the
atmosphere, one of the fuels,
and also carbon monoxide,
one would expect
that ozone should have gone up.
And this is indeed observed.
There are, for instance, records
of ozone, ground level ozone,
going back to the end of
the last century in a suburb
of Paris, Montsouris.
And these are data
which have been checked
by Dieter Klein, his
colleagues, and seem
to indicate good quality
measurements of ozone
at that time.
At that time, about
10 nanomole per mole
were the average
ozone concentrations
which were measured.
And nowadays, in
environments like this
there's just much more
zone, about the effect
of two or three higher.
Also, in the '20s and
'30s, optical measurements
were performed, very often
in the Alp regions in Europe.
And the typical concentrations
of mixing ratios,
which were measured
at that time,
were of the order of,
say, 20 nanomole per mole.
And what is measured typically
nowadays is about 2 times more,
even 3 times more.
And also at station in southern
Germany, Hohenpeissenberg,
we see in the troposphere,
a substantial increase
from data taken in 1968--
these are the annual averages--
and in 1989.
So 20 years progress in
ozone formation here.
This increase in
ozone seems to have
stopped at the
Hohenpeissenberg station.
You see that in the later
years things have leveled off.
Maybe there's even
a slight decrease.
This may have to
do with the fact
that nitrogen oxides are
being regulated in Europe,
so that the maximum
ozone in Hohenpeissenberg
may have been reached though
by the end of the '80s.
Of course, it's
also possible that
some meteorological factors have
played a role in this curve.
We have to further analyze that.
Well, also, models
can be developed.
And when that is done,
the simplest model
we developed in Mainz
about 10 years ago.
There are much more advanced
models now being used.
But I think still
the principles are
what is happening can be
explained with the simple model
we developed.
Also, initially with the help
of Reginald Newell, the model
of transport in chemistry
in the atmosphere,
we basically divide up the
Earth in longitude and latitude
blocks and high
blocks and then take
meteorological observations,
monthly mean wind speeds.
And also a fudge factor, the
added diffusion coefficients
were introduced.
And if you don't add
chemistry to the model,
in this case, carbon monoxide
and methane chemistry,
and also at the ground boundary
layer values of carbon monoxide
and methane, then one
can start playing games.
But one has to consider is that
NO is put into the atmosphere
by lightning.
That's the same, let's
say, between industrial and
pre-industrial times.
But for industrial
times, of course,
we have lots of
inputs of nitrogen
oxide in the industrial world.
And this is then also
assigned to the model.
And then if one calculates
how much ozone this model then
produces, one gets in the
case of the pre-industrial
atmosphere-- and this is
for the summer in July,
pre-industrial atmosphere--
you see a picture which--
well, it's bluish
almost everywhere
with a few exceptions,
roughly of the order of 10,
15 parts per billion or nanomole
per mole near the Earth's
surface for the July case.
You compare that with
the present situation,
and you get a much
more colorful figure.
See you get much enhanced
ozone concentrations, downwind
of the main pollution sources.
So an increase by
roughly effect of 2 or 3
compared to
pre-industrial situation.
So the models basically show
the same as the observations.
If one looks at the budget
of ozone in the troposphere,
we have a number of reactions
in which ozone is formed.
HO2 plus NO O and
CH3O2 plus NO are
the reactions in the carbon
monoxide methane oxidation
schemes.
Any time these
reactions take place,
basically an ozone
molecule is formed.
And you see here on the
global you see two numbers.
One of these numbers
expresses the amount
of ozone produced
in the troposphere
globally in units of 10
to the 12 mole per year.
And the left number
is calculated
for the present atmosphere.
And the right
number is calculated
for the pre-industrial
atmosphere.
And you see the ozone
forming reactions.
You see also O single D
plus water vapor, which
is a loss reaction for ozone.
There is some reaction of ozone
with HO2 and partially with OH
is coming in here.
If you look at the chemical
terms, which are shown here,
you see that the
chemical terms certainly
for the industrial
atmosphere are much larger
than the flux of ozone
downwards from the stratosphere
and also larger than
the destruction of ozone
at the ground.
This clearly shows that
ozone is formed and destroyed
in the troposphere
in amounts, which
are larger than the influx
from the stratosphere.
And interestingly,
this was also already
for the preindustrial
atmosphere.
Although the emissions
of NO were smaller,
still, the chemical terms were
more important than the flux
from the stratosphere.
So the internal budget of
ozone in the troposphere
is regulated by in situ
chemical processes.
And this is, of course, a big
change from the initial belief
that ozone would be a rather
inert gas in the troposphere.
It's, however,
important to point out
that these reactions which
produce and destroy ozone
would never start
if there would not
be some influx from
the stratosphere
into the troposphere.
We have here an
autocatalytic system
in which you need some flux
of ozone to get it started.
But then you actually
produce internally much more
or destroy much more
than the initial flux.
Also, we did some
analysis of this.
If you look at the
ozone in the atmosphere,
although the internal cycle
is so important, still
for the total amount of
ozone in the troposphere,
the stratospheric part
is of large importance.
In the upper part of the
troposphere, most of the ozone
you find there still has an
origin from the stratosphere.
And that's a part, which is
important for climate studies.
Well, I'm getting
to the tropics.
Before that, briefly
show you this figure.
This is basically
the distribution
of ozone, total ozone, as a
function of latitude and time
of the year.
It's only average values.
And what it shows is basically--
this was, by the
way, a figure which
was made before the
ozone hole developed.
So this is a classic figure.
But in general what we
see in this figure is
that in the tropics
there is basically always
some sort of an ozone
hole, a natural ozone hole.
Minimum amount of total
ozone is in the tropics,
which has to do with the height
of the tropo force, which
is much higher 18
kilometers in the tropics
than at high latitudes.
So most ultraviolet
radiation-- by far,
most ultraviolet
radiation comes down
to the surface in the tropics.
And in the tropics you find
also in general a maximum
in water vapor concentration.
So you would expect the
highest production of OH
and the highest OH
concentrations in the tropics.
And although we have very few
measurements to confirm that,
if we rely on model calculation,
we see this clearly.
Here is depicted the
concentration of OH radicals
in the troposphere as
a function of latitude.
Southern hemisphere,
northern hemisphere here.
And then also height and in
units of 10 to 6 molecules
per cubic centimeter.
So we have a maximum here.
That means that
many gases, which
have lifetimes, say, of the
order of a few months or more,
are mainly destroyed
in the tropics.
Examples of such gases
are carbon monoxide--
here also the destruction
rates depicted
as a function of latitude--
and methane.
So this is where the OH
radical is the most active
and most of the cleaning of
the atmosphere is taking place.
The calculations with which
these calculations can
be checked, and earlier we
had a wonderful chemical
product, which was
measured around the world,
for instance, by Ron
Prinn and his colleagues.
And what is shown here
is methyl chloroform.
Methyl chloroform is a compound
which basically is only
produced by the
chemical industry
and it's mainly
destroyed by reaction
with OH in the atmosphere.
And one can compare at various
stations around the world
the calculated and observed
mixing ratios of methyl
chloroform in the atmosphere.
And if you look at
these curves, you
can hardly distinguish them.
This model, as it was
developed about 10 years ago,
gave roughly the right results.
So the OH concentration
cross-section,
which I showed you before,
cannot be too far off from
reality.
And this is very interesting
because I repeat this now
here basically the
curve I have in color,
indicating the breakdown
of carbon monoxide
by reaction with OH.
And methane reaction with OH
in the industrial atmosphere
is this figure.
And you can do the same thing in
the pre-industrial atmosphere.
And you can say
that this represents
the destruction of methane
and carbon monoxide
must, of course, be balanced
by input into the atmosphere.
So you can say that the natural
sources for carbon monoxide
and methane are given by
this lower figure here.
And of the industrial
atmosphere is given here.
So here we've the
natural sources.
Here we have sum of natural
plus anthropogenic sources.
The difference is the
anthropogenic source.
So you can use these sort
of model calculations
to derive budget of
methane in the atmosphere.
And what one finds
then is that at present
of the order of 630
million tons of methane
is used in current atmosphere.
In the pre-industrial, the
natural source of methane
is of the order of 270.
And the difference is, say, 360.
So what this basically
shows is that an input
by human activities of
methane in the atmosphere
is probably somewhat larger than
the natural source of methane
in the atmosphere.
The anthropogenic sources
of methane in the atmosphere
are given here.
The individual
amounts of are still
not answered in many cases.
But at least we know roughly
what the sum of these sources
should be.
And you see here animals
play a large role.
Anaerobic fermentation
is a large source
for methane in the atmosphere.
So ruminants and animal
waste fermentation
is a large source for
methane in the atmosphere.
We have rice fields,
biomass burning, landfills,
and natural gas and
oil industry leaks.
It's interesting to see how
important the animals are.
And I don't know whether you
ever have thought about it,
but say a typical family of
five people, owns 1 point
1/4 of a cow.
So somewhere in
the world there are
lots of cows supplying us here
with cheese and meat and so on.
And we have others here, so
of the order of 10 chicken
just supplying us with meat.
What I showed you
before is already
an indication, a strong
indication, how important
the tropics are in all of this.
To give you an idea about
the fundamental step forward,
which was made by the discovery
how important hydroxyl radicals
are in cleaning
the atmosphere, I
give you this. view graph
some so-called authoritative
estimates, of budget estimates,
of methane and carbon
monoxide in the atmosphere.
In 1968, there was such
an analysis published.
And it claimed that the methane
source from natural wetlands
would be of the order of
1,180 million tonne of methane
per year.
We know now that the real
number is of the order of 270.
At that time, there
simply was no knowledge
at all available
about how things were
removed from the atmosphere.
Anthropogenic
emissions, they were
rather close to each other.
If you look at the CO budget,
you see here number 75 in 1968.
And we know now that the number
here for the natural source
is more like 860.
And the anthropogenic source
was also very strongly
underestimated at that time.
Some of you may think
that the tropics
in the southern
hemisphere are still
clean regions of the atmosphere.
There's very little
industry you might think.
But there is a very important
human activity already taking
place in the tropics.
And that is biomass burning.
Whoever has been in the
tropics during the dry season
knows how polluted
the atmosphere can be.
And here, we have some estimates
of the amount of carbon, which
is burned in the tropics
by various activities,
having to do in many cases with
rather primitive agriculture.
The shift in
agriculture is estimated
that between 1,000 to 2,000
million tonne of carbon
is burned each year
in this activity.
Permanent deforestation,
500 to 1,400.
Savanna fires 400 to 2,000.
Fire wood burning is
better known, 300 to 600.
And agricultural waste
burning, say, 500 to 800 homes.
See these numbers
are very uncertain.
But they add up to roughly
about 3 to 7 times 10
to 15 gram of carbon per year.
This is a very large
amount of biomass, which is
burned in the tropic each year.
And this is dirty burning.
I mean, a lot of pollutants
are coming into the atmosphere.
So this is actually what
is exposed to the fire.
This is what actually is
burned, between 2 and 5 times 10
to the 15 gram of
carbon per year.
And that stuff in that burning,
stuff gets into the atmosphere.
And basically, all
the molecules we
know which are contributing
to photochemical
smog in our part
of the world also
are admitted by biomass
burning in the atmosphere.
In Mainz we have set
up a little laboratory
in which we can burn
materials from different parts
of the world.
And then we look at the
emissions from these materials.
And we find typically we have
the temperature of the fires.
We have the flaming phase and
the smoldering phase here.
And together,
depending on whether we
are on the flaming phase or the
smoldering phase of the fire,
you get different
kinds of pollutants
in the atmosphere, like carbon
dioxide, carbon monoxide,
methane, and many other
hydrocarbons, methyl chloride
and so on.
So a rich menu of compounds are
released into the atmosphere
by biomass burning
in the tropics.
And this is clearly affecting
the level of pollution gases
or background gases
in the tropics,
and not only gases, but also
soot and smoke particles.
Here we have data from Cuiaba.
This is a station in
Mato Grosso in Brazil.
And you see maximum
concentrations
of aerosol in the
atmosphere, coinciding
with the time when
biomass burning is
taking place in Brazil.
Now, these biomass burning
produces, as I said,
the same compounds,
which basically also lead
to photochemical smoke
in our part of the world.
But there's one big difference.
In the tropics this
is a rural phenomenon.
In our part of the world, it's
mainly an urban phenomenon.
So this is covering
much larger areas.
And we see the results
of that they clearly.
We are going from this station
in Mato Grosso in the 1988.
In the month of
September for about half
of the time, half of the days
in the month of September,
the ozone levels,
80 PPB of ozone
was exceeded during the month of
September, the time of biomass
burning in Brazil.
Now this is different
from year to year.
Some years it's just very bad.
Other years it may be better.
This depends on
meteorological conditions.
And it's not only
happening in India Brazil,
but also in, say, Zimbabwe
in southern part of Africa.
What you see here are
profiles of smoke particles
of carbon monoxide,
carbon dioxide, and ozone,
which were measured
by a research team
from our Institute, Andy Andre.
You see these maxima
in concentrations.
And these are the result
of biomass burning, which
doesn't taken place, of
course, at these altitudes
at that time, but had happened
somewhere else near the ground.
And then the air was lifted
to its high altitudes,
where then the ozone was formed.
This phenomena cannot
only been seen in situ,
it can also be seen from space.
Here we have data on the
amount of carbon monoxide
in the troposphere,
which were measured
during the wet season in
the southern hemisphere
and the dry season in
the southern hemisphere.
The blue colors mean very
little CO, relatively little CO.
The red colors mean lots
of CO in the troposphere.
And you see that
in October, there
is more carbon monoxide in the
southern hemisphere than six
months earlier,
basically the dry season,
in the northern hemisphere.
It shows you, you cannot
consider the tropics
in the southern
hemisphere as very clean.
And this is also seen in
the ozone distribution
figure, which comes
from a Jack Fischman.
In the period
September to November,
you see that there is this
outflow, this production
of ozone in the
southern hemisphere,
affecting large parts of
the southern hemisphere,
including Australia
and Tasmania here.
Interestingly,
this model of which
I just showed you some
results before simulates that.
You see this tongue of
relatively high ozone values
extending into the
southern hemisphere.
So there can be a lot of ozone
in the southern hemisphere.
But you can also
have circumstances
in which you hardly
find any ozone
in the southern hemisphere.
And that is in regions
where basically you
are far away from
the continents,
from the inputs of anthropogenic
and also natural hydrocarbons
and nitrogen oxides
in the atmosphere.
In 1993, we did measurements.
This was an activity by the
Center for Studies of Climate
and Clouds at the
Scripps Institution
of Oceanography in collaboration
with Dieter Klein in Germany.
A cruise was made from
Honiara to Solomon Islands
to Christmas Island.
And during this
cruise, balloons were
launched into the atmosphere.
And ozone was measured.
And what was often mentioned
was ozone profiles which
looked like this, close to the
tropopause, hardly any ozone,
it was gone.
And also in the
lower troposphere,
rather low concentrations
of ozone in the troposphere.
This was expected.
But that we could end
up with such low ozone
values in the upper
troposphere, that was new.
And it was not only
measured on one profile.
But it was measured on several
profiles, several locations.
And this is shown in
these panels here.
You see very often
situations in which
ozone goes down to almost
zero here and here again, etc.
So this was a big surprise.
And I'm not sure that we
understand very well why
this is happening.
So if we consider the enormous
importance of the hydroxyl
radical in keeping
the atmosphere clean,
and we realize how
important ozone
is as a precursor
for hydroxyl radicals
and how hydroxyl
radicals are mainly
located in the troposphere,
we must, of course,
wonder about the ozone
distribution in the tropics.
We cannot say that this
distribution of ozone
in the tropics is a very
regular distribution,
because it's highly variable.
We can have situations
with very little ozone.
Or we can have situations
with much more ozone, whenever
we are under the influence of
biomass burning for instance.
So in order to understand
the atmospheric chemistry,
we have to understand what
is happening in the tropics.
And we have to understand
the distribution of ozone
in the tropics.
And unfortunately, if
you look at the stations
where the measurements in the
tropics are occasionally made,
they are very few.
Just far too few to set up a
good basis, quantitative basis
for our studies.
So one of the
messages of my talk
is that we have to improve on
that situation very strongly.
I would like to show you
at the end the few most
recent results.
I showed you before
this figure, which
indicates the oxidation
schematically of isoprene
in the atmosphere.
Isoprene is emitted
from tropical forests
in large amounts
in the atmosphere.
And during its oxidation very
interesting chemical things
happen.
And these were measured by us.
In the beginning of last
year, we had an expedition.
In Suriname, this is
the former Dutch Guiana,
where we on an aircraft
measured in situ
the distribution of
isoprene and products,
which are derived from
isoprene in the atmosphere,
with a new instrument, the
proton transfer reaction mass
spectrometer.
And whenever we were
in the boundary layer--
here we have the flight
route of the plane--
whenever we were in boundary
layer, we saw isoprene,
and we saw methyl vinyl ketone
and also hydroxy hydroperoxide,
which derives from isoprene.
So they're all there.
And the effect, the
model which we developed
gave roughly the same results.
The Lagrangian model fed
by emission of isoprene
from the forest gave about the
amounts which were mentioned.
In fact, it was so much isoprene
was emitted in the atmosphere
that it ditrated hydroxyl
radicals to a large degree.
So the average OH
concentration, average
over 24 hours in the boundary
layer over the forest, which
calculated was only 2
times 10 to the 5 molecules
per cubic centimeter.
It's a very low amount
for a tropical region.
We saw other stuff
in surprisingly high
concentrations.
One compound which is of
substantial importance is--
of course, carbon
monoxide we saw,
but also we saw
acetone mixing ratios
of the order of 2 nanomole
per mole and even more.
And acetone it turns out-- this
is research of the last 5 to 10
years--
is an important source
for hydroxyl radicals
at high altitudes.
So it's definitely formed
in the tropics in the forest
regions in large amounts.
And we also saw acitonitrile.
This is a product
of biomass burning
in the tropics and
elsewhere of course.
Finally some results from a more
recent campaign in the tropics.
The Indo X campaign
which was conducted
last February, March in
the Indian Ocean region
with a base in the Maldives.
During this experiment, which
occupied some 150 scientists
from all around the
world, including India,
during this experiment,
many measurements
were made from
ships, from aircraft,
and also ground based.
The idea about
this experiment was
to see whether the
pollution, which
is produced over the
Indian continent,
in general south
and southeast Asia,
whether it could reach
the Indian Ocean region.
So we went out there.
And we also went south of the
ITCZ, Intertropical Convergence
Zone.
And you see a nice atmosphere,
not too dirty, rather clean.
But then, mostly we were
south of the Intertropical
Convergence Zone.
And there it looked like this.
It was dirty over
very large regions.
Down to the ITCZ, the
Indian Ocean region
was highly polluted.
It was polluted
to such an extent
that-- and mostly what
you see is the particles,
the absorption optical
depth of the particles
could be of the order of 0.04.
So this rather dark stuff
which was out there.
And the effect on
the radiation balance
of a substantial region over the
Indian Ocean is considerable.
So some estimates indicate
that under these conditions
about 20% of the solar
radiation, which normally
should reach the surface of
the ocean didn't arrive there.
It was either absorbed
in the atmosphere
or backscattered to space.
So this was a rather
shocking experience for us.
And we were curious
to find something.
We were a little worried that
maybe we don't find anything,
because it's so far away
from the pollution source.
But that we would
find such a situation
was a big surprise
for everybody for us.
So that shows that we
have to start already now
worrying about what is
happening in the tropics
and in the developing world.
I mean, this is where
most of the action
will be in the future.
And this is my pitch, of course.
I mean, that's where
much more effort
should go into this research.
We have to find out what is
happening in the tropics.
And we have so few
data at the moment.
So I hope that with your
support and a little propaganda,
we can do much more of
these kinds of experiments.
I thank you for your attention.
And I hope there's still
allowed some questions.
[APPLAUSE]
MODERATOR: Questions
and comments?
AUDIENCE: Where
did this pollution
come from that you showed us.
CRUTZEN: From India and
Southeast Asia and probably
also China.
It's a huge population behind
it, some 2,000 million people.
AUDIENCE: Fuel burning?
CRUTZEN: Yes, it's wood burning.
I think that's part of it.
But there's also lots
of dirty burning.
We have to find out actually
where it all came from.
But it contained a large
amount of absorbing aerosol.
So it's different
from sulfate aerosol.
AUDIENCE: Paul, there are
actually some HOx measurements
in the tropical troposphere last
time I was reading about it.
CRUTZEN: Which measurements?
AUDIENCE: HOx.
CRUTZEN: HOx.
Oh, I haven't looked into that.
When I said the model
agreed rather well
with what was observed, this
was for the boundary layer.
You referred to the
measurements in Suriname?
AUDIENCE: No, I'm talking
about the HOx measurement
from here too.
CRUTZEN: Yeah, well, I have
not developed any model
calculations for that.
AUDIENCE: Do you expect similar
situations with biomass burning
in Africa and the Amazon.
Is there any evidence
for the similar extension
of the pollution?
CRUTZEN: I don't know.
I mean, we have to go out there.
I mean, of course,
far fewer people
living in these other
parts of the world.
I think we should
follow up on this.
AUDIENCE: If you
look at the tropics,
and you look at this large scale
perturbations to the chemical
composition to
[INAUDIBLE] are you more
worried about the impact of
the chemicals per se or are
you worried [INAUDIBLE]
between chemicals [INAUDIBLE]
CRUTZEN: The latter I am more.
Worried about, yes,
that's right word.
But on the other
hand, of course,
it's also highly,
awfully interesting
finding out more about this.
But what does this all mean?
I mean when suddenly 20%
of the solar radiation
is not appearing at
the Earth's surface.
It must do something.
Maybe not immediately.
Maybe we are in the process
of building up some something.
MOLINA: We made a
question [INAUDIBLE]
you would need a budget
comparing [INAUDIBLE]
What about OH?
What do the models--
CRUTZEN: Well, for OH, I
would not trust the models.
I mean, we roughly are
in the right ballpark.
And I mean, we were very lucky
when we got these results.
And with additional
chemistry, we
have added to the
model in the meanwhile.
We actually get somewhat
different results,
which still look quite good, but
not so good as indicated here.
So it means that in the
current models, which
are more advanced, there's
something missing, which
we did not discover
before when we had
much more simplified models.
So this is sort
of contradictory,
but this is the case.
Rowland can better
answer this question
of what is happening to OH.
You cannot say in general
OH will grow or decrease
by so and so many percent.
It would be parts
of the world where
hydroxyl will
increase wherever you
put more NO in the atmosphere.
And the other parts
of the world where
it will decrease because
more carbon monoxide
is put into the atmosphere.
And the global balance,
I don't think our models
are, by far, not good enough
to derive lower balance.
I think we need traces to do
that and other means will do.
AUDIENCE: We published
a paper a few years ago
claiming that it was
about 0 plus or minus 0.2%
or 0.3% per year.
So it's rather small.
About all we do now to modify
that [INAUDIBLE] equals 0.
CRUTZEN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Sometimes [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Well, I
think [INAUDIBLE]..
There are really two sets
of problems connected
with the less developed world.
One is the pollution where
people aren't, which you just
showed us.
The other is the
pollution where people
are in these mega cities, where
the air is even much worse when
measured out in
the Indian Ocean.
And it's very difficult
to get resources
to study either problem.
But what I wonder is to
what extent the emissions
from converging and
multiplying mega cities
in less the
developed world, what
the magnitude of that impact
is on a regional, semi-global
scale versus the story
that you told us today
about biomass burning.
It's not clear to me that
the two impacts [INAUDIBLE]
similar magnitude.
CRUTZEN: Well, the Indo
X pollution, I think,
was not only biomass
burning, but it can also
be dirty coal burning and
all of that stuff behind it.
So we simply have to find out.
But I mean what will happen in
the future with the big city
glomerates, I mean, with 30
million people living together,
how that will change the overall
chemistry of the atmosphere
is a very important question.
I mean, what is better, to
spread out all this pollution
over a large area or put it
all together mainly big cities?
You create totally different
types of aerosol, for instance.
The coagulation of cities
is so much stronger.
And so what the developments
of that will be--
I mean, the influence of
cities even on the global scale
is, I think, a very interesting
and important issue.
AUDIENCE: Well, let me ask
a question on the main theme
that there needs to be more
studies in the chemistry.
Most of the probable countries
are developing countries
and they don't have
a lot of resources
to do this type of work.
I mean the instrumentation
and certainly [INAUDIBLE]
expensive [INAUDIBLE].
How many Indians were
in Indo X for example?
How many Indian scientists
were [INAUDIBLE]??
CRUTZEN: Quite many, quite many.
I mean if I would
guess now, probably
of the order of 30 to 50.
So they were mainly on one of
the ships, the Sagar Kanya.
And really some, quite a few
of them do excellent work.
So it's not a
hopeless situation.
But, of course, you
raise an important point.
How do you get more
of these people
in developing countries
into this game?
It's high technology.
I mean, you can
educate people here,
but do they go home to their
country and to do the research?
They stay here because
when they go home,
there's nothing to do there.
The governments
are not interested.
But there you sit at
international negotiations,
and there you see
most of the scientists
from the developing countries
sitting in the back rows
and not saying much.
And so they do not
inform their governments.
So you have this
terrible vicious circle
of things, which in some
way, we have to break.
But how we is not
clear to me either.
MOLINA: I think that's question
about being a little bit
better for the large
cities because there are
more resources in the cities.
And so there's at least more
scientists in the developing
countries looking at that.
Of course that doesn't mean
that more needs to be done.
But as far as the rural
areas, I think at the moment,
I would agree with you
very little is done.
But there's also
scientific question
I thought of that you raised.
This difference between
spreading out the pollution
or getting it in cities,
because [INAUDIBLE] and you
sort of alluded to
one that the isoprene
was titrated [INAUDIBLE].
We can also envision [INAUDIBLE]
they need to destroy ozone.
So all sorts of--
CRUTZEN: And then more
efficiently removed then
maybe if you put them all
together in a smaller--
So what is the effect
of urbanization
in the next century especially
on atmospheric chemistry
is an interesting question.
It has its positive
and negative sides.
Well, I don't think
at all, of course,
how young kids will grow up in
cities with 30 million people.
That's a totally
different problem.
That's a social question,
which I find horrifying.
MOLINA: Well, let's
thank our speaker again.
And I invite you all
to the ninth floor
where we have a
reception [INAUDIBLE]
further celebrate
our [INAUDIBLE]..
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]